so our last talk for this morning will
be by anthony nielsen and it's about
final schemes of the ceremony
thanks uh thanks to the organizers for
the invitation it's a real pleasure to
be back in berkeley
this is all joint work with melody chan
who's sitting back there she's giving a
fabulous colloquium talk this afternoon
which i think doesn't conflict with any
of the talks here
so
please go ahead and check that out
i'm going to be speaking about final
schemes of determinants and permanence
so let's start out by looking at the
space of singular matrices right so what
is this
i'm just looking so i'll denote this by
d sub n
this consists of those n by n matrices
over c
which have vanishing determinant okay so
this is a hyper surface in matrix space
cn squared it's cut out by the degree n
determinant polynomial
so this is a basic object that we've
been talking about all week long right
so just for example we can look at d2
the space of singular two by two
matrices this is cut out by the
polynomial x one one x two two minus x
one two x two one
and so what i'd like to start out
talking about is the following question
what linear subspaces in matrix space
and cn squared are actually contained in
this hyper surface of singular matrices
in other words what are linear spaces of
singular matrices
so this is really quite a classical
question and it's got some connections
to geometric complexity theory which
i'll talk about
in a second but let's take a look at
some examples first
okay so here are two examples
the one on the left is probably the
easiest example so this is an n minus 1
times n dimensional space of matrices
i'm looking at those matrices where i'm
allowing anything i want
in the bottom n minus 1 rows and i have
zeros in the top row
okay and so if you look at the laplace
expansion of the determinant you
immediately see these are all singular
matrices so they're contained in my
hypersurface dn
so this is our first example this is an
n minus 1 times n dimensional space of
linear
of singular matrices so the second
example here on the right this is maybe
a little more tricky so here we have a
five dimensional linear space of
matrices i'm just zeroing out the upper
left two by two block and so we might
ask well how do we how do we see that
these are all in fact singular matrices
so i can think about these all as being
linear maps from c3 to c3
and if i look at what they're doing i
see that the two dimensional space
spanned by my first two basis vectors is
being compressed down to the
one-dimensional space spanned by the
third basis vector
so i'm compressing something
two-dimensional down to something
one-dimensional that means each one of
these maps has to be singular as well so
again
i now have a five-dimensional linear
space of singular matrices
so you can do a similar construction
to get what is called a compression
space
so what's what's the setup here uh and
these so these actually uh sort of
appeared in vayment's talk um i can take
an s dimensional vector space w and s
plus one dimensional vector space v
these are both subspaces of c to the n
and now i look at all those matrices
which are mapping this s plus 1
dimensional space v
into the s dimensional space w so this
is a linear condition on my matrices so
it gives me a linear subspace of
matrices
and since i'm compressing something s
plus one dimensional down to something s
dimensional
this means that this this is a singular
linear map okay so this gives me some
linear subspace of dn
which we'll call a compression space
and these are the linear spaces of
singular matrices which are easy to
understand these are these are somehow
the ones that we have a good handle on
okay
all right
so we've seen some examples of linear
spaces of singular matrices what's the
connection to geometric complexity
theory
okay so we're all trying to understand
valiance conjecture comparing the
complexity of the permanent to the
complexity of the determinant and so we
have this geometric approach
due to momoli and sahoni that says what
we really need to do is we need to
understand the orbit closure of the
determinant polynomial in this space of
degree n polynomials and n squared
variables if we can somehow understand
the the boundary of this uh we'll be
well on our way uh to understanding
valiance conjecture i mean we need to
understand something about the permanent
two but this is this would already be an
immense step if we had a good idea of
what this boundary was
and so
this is where these maximal linear
subspaces of singular matrices come into
play
so there's an idea due to landsberg
manival and lacer
that says well if you have a maximal
linear subspace of singular matrices you
can actually use this to construct a
curve in gln squared and if you look at
the linea the limiting behavior of this
curve on your determinant polynomial
you're going to produce potentially some
interesting piece in the boundary of the
orbit closure of the determinant
so they did this to produce i guess
something in the something that was
previously unknown in the
boundary of the orbit closure of the
three by three determinant
so this is the connection to
at least one of the connections between
linear subspaces of singular matrices
and this
geometric complexity theory
so this is not really what i'm going to
be talking about
i just really like to focus on the
question what do we know about linear
subspaces of singular matrix
okay so as an algebraic geometer i find
that the most natural way of approaching
this problem is through a parameter
space called the fano scheme
so what's the kth funnel scheme of my
hypersurface dn
this is just going to be the set of all
k plus one dimensional linear spaces
which are contained in the hyper-surface
dn okay so this is what this final
scheme is as a set
of course this is naturally a subset of
my grasmanian grk plus one n squared
which is parameterizing k plus
one-dimensional linear spaces in an
n-squared dimensional vector space
this thing has the structure of an
algebraic variety it turns out that this
fano scheme is a closed subset of this
algebraic variety so it can also think
about it as an algebraic variety
really i should be thinking about it as
a scheme it potentially has some
non-reduced structure
but this isn't so important so i'm going
to gloss over this
okay so my goal really in understanding
linear spaces of singular matrices boils
down to understanding what these funnel
schemes look like for different values
of k
and so
really what i want to do is i want to
study the geometry of these final
schemes
all right so i should mention um
of course if k is equal to zero here i'm
looking at one-dimensional uh spaces of
singular matrices this is somehow
uninteresting right anytime i have a
singular matrix i can scale it by
non-zero constants this gives me a
unique line of
singular matrices so things really
become interesting when k is at least
equal to one
so let's look at maybe the first
first case
so here we're going to look at planes of
singular two by two matrices okay so
this is where k is equal to one and n is
equal to two
so we'd already seen one example of a
plane of singular two by two matrices
this was on our second slide and the
example that we have just on the left
here i'm zeroing out the top row
of course
there's no reason that i couldn't
transpose this and get a different plane
of singular two by two matrices this is
the second example that i have here
and of course
there are many more planes of singular
2x2 matrices which i have
i can act on these two planes
by row and column operations
to get two different families
so both of these families
are parametrized by two parameters
so on the left by lambda 0 and lambda 1
on the right by mu 0 and mu 1
and as long as both parameters don't
simultaneously vanish i'll indeed get a
plane of
singular 2x2 matrices
and this plane
it's actually just determined by the
ratio between these two parameters so
these are two families which are both
parametrized by my complex projective y
so
i have a map from the disjoint union of
two complex projective lines into this
fano scheme and it actually turns out
that this is everything
every plane of singular two by two
matrices is of the form that i have here
in the middle of the slide so this
funnel scheme is just the disjoint union
of two copies of p1
so topologically it's the disjoint union
of two spheres we see that it's
disconnected
and of course this shouldn't come as a
surprise at all right this hyper surface
that i'm looking at is if i if i think
about it in projective space this is
just a non-singular quadratic surface
we all know that any non-singular
quadratic surface has exactly two
distinct rulings these two components
that i have are corresponding exactly to
the two different families of lines that
i have on this quadratic surface
any questions so far
great so let's move on to think about
planes of singular n by n matrices
so this situation is already pretty well
understood
uh so chronicle chronic or normal form
which gives a normal normal form for
pencils of matrices implies in fact that
any plane of singular n by n matrices
is actually going to be contained in
some compression space
so these linear spaces of singular
matrices which we understand quite well
we can use these to understand at least
what all the points in these final
schemes are right this doesn't tell us
yet so much about the geometry so this
is
my first contribution together with
melody we can actually say something
about the geometry of this final scheme
so our statement is that this final
scheme f1 of dn parameterizing planes of
singular n by n matrices this has
exactly n irreducible components so we
know exactly what these pieces are and
each one of these components has
dimension 2 times n squared minus 2
minus n plus 1. so this is this is the
remarkable thing they all have the same
dimension this might not be something
that you would necessarily expect
and this dimension that they all have
this is what's called the expected
dimension what does this mean
anytime i have a fano scheme of a hyper
surface
it's actually cut out by a section the
the section of some vector bundle living
on my grasmanian
and the rank of so the rank of this
vector bundle is the number of
conditions that this section is giving
me
and we say that our final scheme has the
expected code dimension if the code
dimension in the grasmanian is exactly
the rank of this vector bundle and well
expected dimension is defined in a
similar fashion right so somehow what
this is actually saying
is that the behavior of planes
of singular matrices is exactly the same
as you would expect if you're looking at
planes uh contained in any homogeneous
any hypersurface any general
hypersurface of degree atom so somehow
with respect to
two-dimensional linear spaces the
determinant is generic
for the dimension
the fact to have uh
yeah okay so it's not entirely right so
so for a generic hypersurface of course
you'd expect that um
one component that's right so it's yes
so it it's proper the the the the the
the this modulus is the idea of the
expected dimension people dealt with
proper
so
no so they're not smooth in fact none of
the components are smooth except in the
in the in the two by two case
yeah yeah so um yeah
and so some of these components we
understand quite well because they're
really all coming from these compression
spaces and so we and for any component
of this form we can tell you exactly
when it's smooth and when it's not
smooth okay is connected
yes so for n bigger than two it's
connected we'll get to that in a in a
minute or two okay
any other questions
okay so
this is pretty good we understand the
case of planes of singular and by n
matrices well uh what can we tell us
what the components are yeah so i mean
somehow the point is that they're all
just compression spaces yeah they're um
they're all coming from compression
spaces yeah
this is in different types of that right
so there's somehow n different types of
compression spaces and each one of these
will give me a different irreducible
component that's maybe
not immediately clear but it's true
and
so it's the
different pairs k and k plus one that's
right that's right
okay so what can we say about higher
dimensional linear spaces uh maybe the
first question we should ask is well
what's the maximum dimension that a
linear space of singular matrices can
even have so this was answered a while
ago by judy
who said that this final scheme fk of dn
is non-empty
if and only if k is less than n times n
minus one in other words the maximum
dimension that a linear space of
singular matrices can have is equal to n
times n minus 1. we've already seen that
this dimension is realized right this
very first example that we had where we
just zeroed out the first row of a
matrix this does the trick the theorem
says that you can't get anything of
dimension higher than that
okay so this was somehow the good news
this is what we understand the rest of
the slide is mainly bad news
so if we're in this range where our
final scheme is non-empty but k is
larger than one
lots of bad stuff happens uh so this
phenomenon that we had in the case of
planes where our final scheme had pure
dimension uh this almost never will
happen
we have no real clue what the
irreducible components are so there's
been some previous work on this which
tells us what the irreducible components
are when k is large relative to n so
this is work due to beasley and in the
case of small matrices so for n equals
three or four there's some work by
atkinson and later eisenberg and harris
that tell us exactly what the components
are
there's some work by andreisma which
gives us another component
in some other cases but in general we
really don't have a handle at all on
what these components are and this seems
to be a very very difficult problem
which unfortunately i can't say anything
about either
there are other bad things that happen
too so if you want to think about your
final scheme really as being a scheme
instead of being a variety in general
it's going to have non-reduced structure
and this actually happens
and it has really bad singularities so
the geometry somehow is is very
complicated uh so
maybe it's it's good to take a step back
and ask slightly easier questions that
we can actually answer
so one of these questions would be well
when exactly is this final scheme
connected so this is this is somehow a
very natural thing to ask these final
schemes are special
special examples of hilbert schemes
which are parameterizing some
some sub-varieties with fixed hilbert
polynomial of a given projective variety
the classical hilbert scheme
parameterizing sub-varieties with fixed
tilbert polynomial
of projective space is connected this is
due to
this classical result of heartsworn
and so it really
is is well motivated to ask
when is uh this example of a hilbert
scheme namely our final scheme connected
so the melody and i are able to provide
a complete characterization for which
values of k and n our final scheme is
connected
so this behavior
is largely governed by
this quadratic polynomial kappa of s so
here i've fixed n
and cap of s is then equal to n squared
minus n minus s times s plus 1 minus
okay so our theorem then says well let's
take k to be in the range where our
final scheme is not empty
then this fano scheme is disconnected if
and only if
k is either between n k is larger than n
squared minus two n and less than or
equal to kappa of zero
or there exists some integer s in
between zero and n minus one
such that cap of s minus the minimum of
n minus s minus one and s is less than k
which in turn is less than or equal to
cap of s okay so this is a mouthful uh
it seems like a rather complicated thing
but it's definitely something that tells
you exactly when our final scheme is
connected so let's take a look and see
what this is telling us for
low values of n
so we'd already seen that in the case n
equals 2 our final scheme is these two
just disjoint copies of p1 so it's
disconnected
for n equals 3 our final scheme
according to this theorem will be
connected if k is less than or equal to
3 for n equals 4 if k is less than or
equal to 8 for n equals 5 if k is less
than or equal to 13. now the interesting
start stuff starts to happen when n is
equal to 6
here we get that the final scheme is
connected if and only if k is less than
or equal to 21 or k is equal to 24.
so we have some kind of non-monotonic
behavior in the connectedness of these
fauna schemes and this is what happens
in general so as long as n is larger
than two
the final scheme
will be connected for low values of k
and it'll be disconnected for high
values of k
and in between it can jump back and
forth by being connected and
disconnected and this is really coming
from this quadratic polynomial kappa
together with this
existence condition of some integer s
any questions about the theorem i'm
slightly confused about your statement
of the theorem
so you say k is less than equal to kappa
but kappa 0 is exactly n squared minus n
minus 1
sure so why why did you put that kappa 0
there well it somehow fits in nicely
with this kappa s here i mean you can
replace it in your mind if you wish but
it unifies the upper
yeah it makes makes things look a little
more uniform
so if we didn't know your theorem ahead
of time because we had
computed on the caller two for instance
the first couple of cases
um
is there a way to discover this
so for
maybe for um
k equals two and n equals three
um and also maybe for
uh
the sort of very high values of k
and n equals maybe three four five
but um other than that either you need
to be very clever when you're using
macaulay too or i don't know how
but
yeah the i mean
computation becomes difficult very very
quickly
okay so i'd like to say a couple words
about the proof
so really one key to the proof is
understanding these compression spaces
so just to recall
uh for an integer s an s compression
space is the space of matrices which are
compressing some fixed s plus one
dimensional space v
into an s dimensional space w
and this is where this kappa of s is
really coming from so cap of s turns out
to be the projective dimension of any s
s compression space
of course we should keep in mind what
what values can s take s is going to
vary between 0 and n minus one right
the largest thing that i could think
about compressing would be all of c to
the n so i'm compressing something
n minus one plus one dimensional down to
something n minus one dimension
okay so the nice thing about these
compression spaces is that they actually
fit together in a coherent way so if i
look at so i've fixed some k fix some s
and i can look at the set of all k plus
one dimensional subspaces
which are contained in some s
compression space and it turns out that
these form an irreducible component of
this final scheme
so these are going to be somehow the
components that we understand well
we're going to call them compression
space components
okay so the other thing that we need is
we need to use the fact that this final
scheme comes with a taurus action
so of course i can act my space of
matrices just by scaling rows or scaling
columns
this preserves my determinate polynomial
so it acts on my singular space of
matrices
and this induces an action on this final
scheme as well
and this taurus action turns out to be
very very nice
there are only finitely many fixed
points
and
we understand exactly what these fixed
points are and they all lie on one of
these compression space components
somehow they're in this part of the the
final scheme that we understand okay all
right because they're all quark
right right i mean so
they're all coordinates but you still
have to prove a lemon to show that
they're they're actually in compression
spaces
yeah i mean this is this is yeah this is
some kind of
yeah
okay so here's an example right uh i'm
looking at uh this four-dimensional
linear space singular matrices
and uh
if i act on this space by scaling rows
or scaling columns nothing is going to
change i'm going to still have the same
four-dimensional linear space of
singular matrices so this is a taurus
fixed point in this final scheme f3 of
d3
and of course we see that this is
contained in a compression space right
my
one-dimensional space spanned by the
third basis vector is being compressed
down to zero okay so this was contained
in a zero compression space for example
okay so let me give you an argument now
which would prove that certain final
schemes are in fact connected
so the first observation
is that if i can show that just all
these compression space components are
connected then my fauna scheme has to be
connected why is this true well if i
take any other component
it has to contain so it's a projective
variety so it's going to have to contain
one of the taurus fixed points so it has
to intersect one of my compression space
components
all right so i want to just check now
whether my compression space components
are connected how can i do this well if
two compression space components
intersect their intersection will also
have to contain a torus fixed point so
what i really need to do is just check
which torus fixed points are in which
compress compression spaces
so let's go ahead and do this for an
example so this is the example of four
planes of singular three by three
matrices
and so i've written down some taurus
fixed points here these aren't all of
them but if i allow myself row and
column permutations then this actually
gives me everything okay so let's just
take a look at the one
on the upper left this is the one from
the previous slide
we'd already seen that it was contained
in an s equals zero compression space
component but it's also contained in the
s equals one compression space component
right if i take the linear space span by
the second and third basis vectors this
is compressed down to the space spanned
by the first basis effect so it's an s
equals one component and you can
complete the rest of the picture
similarly
in particular we see that anyone any two
of these compression space components
intersect and our final scheme is in
fact connected okay
so what this gives you is some kind of
combinatorial criterion uh to show that
certain fauna schemes are in fact
connected and so there's
rather complicated i mean you saw what
it was in the
two slides ago but it's something that
you can write down
so this is an argument to show
connectedness of the final scheme
i guess what's happening is you you have
one or two more zeros than you would you
that you expect because your your
dimension your dimension is four and
seven that's right that's right that
allows you to fit them together that's
right exactly if you uh didn't allow
yourself as many zeros as you wanted for
example if you had a star here and a
star here as well this would only be
contained in one compression space so
this is actually what we're going to see
apply behind your result right
that's right that's right
so this is this slide is actually the
slightly more
subtle subtle argument how do you show
disconnectedness all right so
in order to show disconnectedness i
claim that it suffices to exhibit the
existence of a compression space
component
whose taurus fixed points are all smooth
points of the final scheme why is this
true well it's not difficult to see that
you always have at least two irreducible
components of your final scheme
if you have one irreducible component
whose torus fixed points are all smooth
points this tells you it can't intersect
any other component and so your final
scheme has to be disconnected but it's i
thought this is just it can't intersect
any other compressions but it's space
so
anytime i have a component which
intersects another component
the intersection has to contain a torus
fixed point
independent dot just independent of
compression spaces
i mean this is since everything has this
this tourist action the taurus will also
act on the intersection
yeah any projective variety which is a
tourist action
exactly yeah this is a fact that is yeah
okay so we need to show that some
compression space exists uh whose chorus
fixed points are all smooth let's look
at an example here
so now instead of looking at four planes
of singular three by three matrices
we're looking at five planes of singular
three by three matrices
um
and so again there are these three
compression space components and we've
got a number of taurus fixed points
these are all of them again up to row
and column permutations and as frank was
pointing out we now see that each one of
these taurus fixed points is actually
only contained in a single compression
space component
of course
this by itself isn't enough to show that
the final scheme is disconnected it
could be that there's some other
irreducible component that we don't know
about that connects say s equals zero
and s equals one and another one
connecting s equals one and s equals two
however in this example it turns out
that all the taurus fixed points are
actually smooth points in the final
scheme so these guys can't intersect
anything else in fact this tells us
there aren't any other irreducible
components that we didn't know about
so what you have to do is you have to do
some deformation theoretic calculation
to calculate what the tangent space is
at each one of these taurus fixed points
and see whether or not you have a smooth
point
this again gives you some criterion and
the real magic is that this agrees with
what the criterion was that we had from
the previous slide ah pre-worry this
doesn't have to happen
so this is something which nice which
happens and we're able to get this
complete characterization
okay so let me
well not return to but at least
turn direction again and head a little
bit back in the direction of complexity
theory
so
up till now i've been talking about the
fauna scheme of the determinate
hypersurface but of course we can talk
about fauna schemes of any hypersurface
anytime i have a hypersurface i can look
at the set of all linear spaces of some
fixed dimension which are contained in
it so we can do exactly the same for the
permanent polynomial and get a final
scheme fk pn
and so we in our work we study this as
well
so pn is the hyper surface cut out by
the end permanent yeah
um so
so yeah
by the way so you you have proved in
particular that all these final scheme
for the determinant
uh have only even rational chromology
and the island point card is exactly the
number of its points
you get that as a as a bonus oh okay i
wasn't aware of
this integrally there may be but
rationally there is no odd chromology
and the other point curry of your of
your final scale variety is exactly the
number of fixed points
right i'm just generally
let's maybe talk about this when i'm
done all right
all right so
the case of the permanent is slightly
more difficult
we're still able to get a partial
characterization of the connectedness
for these final schemes but there are
some sort of intermediate cases where
you can't really decide
there's some irreducible components
which we understand well which are sort
of the analog of the compression space
components in the determinant case
and again they play an important role in
our
discussion of the connectedness but
somehow they're not there aren't enough
of them for us to really be able to get
a complete characterization of
connectedness
so
going back to complexity theory if
you're trying to somehow show that the
the permanent is inherently different
than the determinant you might want to
just try and compare their final schemes
this would somehow be a naive thing to
do
and it really appears that the final
scheme for the permanent is much more
complicated than that of the determinant
just as an example if you look at the
final scheme parameterizing
four-dimensional linear spaces in the
three by three case for the determinant
you've only got three irreducible
components we already saw what they were
for the permanent you turn out to have
21 and their intersection behavior is
pretty terrible
already you see some non-reduced
structure there so
um
that's right yeah is it the reason for
what you should explain
so this this is one reason that explains
why you get many components but there
are some other components that crop up
that
seem kind of mysterious that we don't
understand very well
how do the dimensions vary
um so at least if you're looking at
high dimensional
linear spaces
um the dimension in the determinant case
is larger than the dimension in the
permanent case
so some other point is if i take a
maximum compression space
i can deform this
but if i take
say
this linear space here so the six
dimensional linear space is also um in
the hyper surface cut up by the three
three by three permanent this doesn't
deform within the permanent at all
so it's a single single point so in fact
um if i look at
uh f's
my question was how the dimensions of
these components vary
in the permanent and versus sort of
determinants right and so what i said
was that at least when k is large
relative to n the dimension for the
permanent is much higher than the
dimension for the sorry the dimension
for the determinant is much higher than
the dimension for the permanent and when
it's very small
so
we conjecture
so right so when when k is equal to one
then we know what the dimension is for
all the components in in the determinant
case that's the expected dimension and
we conjecture that the same is true for
the permanent we know that this is true
when n is equal to three and four
but um don't know for higher values of n
so this is an interesting question uh do
you have a conjecture about the gross
rate of the number of components for the
terminal
so when k is large relative to n we know
what all of them are
but for intermediate values of k
we
really have no idea
for k equals
one again we would conjecture that you
have exactly n components but
sort of in the intermediate range we
don't know
okay so
this is one connection back to this gct
program
let me maybe
on this last slide here talk about
something slightly more naive
so
anytime i have a form of degree d
its product rank is just the smallest
smallest natural number r such that i
can write f
as the sum of r products of linear forms
okay so this is some other notion of
rank similar to rank of a tensor or
similar to wearing rank slightly
different though okay
so we might act ask well what's what's
the product rank of the permanent
so there's a formula due to glenn which
lets you write the three by three
permanent as a sum
of
the four products of linear forms so we
know that the product rank is less than
or equal to four
and i claim that the
product rank is actually equal to four
so i want to use
some argument involving the final scheme
f5 of p3
to show that the product rank cannot has
to be larger than three
so there are
probably many other arguments you can
use
the reason that i'm presenting this is
is to illustrate that
considering final schemes might be
useful in other similar questions
involving rank
all right so what's the argument
so let's suppose so so maybe i should
preface this by saying that we know
exactly what this
this final scheme f5 of p3 is so we've
seen one point which is inside it here's
another point which is inside it
so i can just take
this thing here and of course i could
have zeroed out different rows or
columns and so this gives me six points
in this final scheme and this is in fact
everything
okay so we want to use this knowledge to
our
advantage right so let's suppose that we
can write the three by three permanent
as a sum
of three products of linear forms
so i have nine linear forms that are
appearing here these lij and there are
two cases which can occur either they
can be linearly dependent or not now if
they're linearly dependent
and i look at the final scheme of the
hypersurface cut out by this polynomial
it's not difficult to see that any
maximal linear space contained in this
hypersurface is going to contain some
some common line right
but of course
this is not true for this final scheme
here so these final schemes are
different hence the permanent cannot be
written like this so we've eliminated
this case now let's assume that
in fact these lij are all linearly
independent
let's again look at the final scheme now
of
six planes in this hypersurface how can
i get a
what's one way of producing a six plane
well for each term in the sum
i can zero out exactly one of the lijs
okay so this gives me three times three
times three
different ways of producing
six planes contained in this
hypersurface which tells me that my
final scheme has at least 27 points but
i know that it only had six points so
this is also impossible
so of course
there are probably easier ways of
showing this fact
but
similar arguments i'm hoping might be
applicable in other situations where you
don't when you talk to computer
scientists you should tell them you have
a lower bound for the smallest step
three circuit
okay so this gives a lower bond for the
smallest step three circuit of the
permanent
yeah all right
yeah so on on that note let me let me
stop thanks
do you know what i missed
yes yes yes
yes so in fact this this is always true
so if i look at um
f n squared minus n minus 1. that's
right so if i look at f
n squared minus n minus 1 of p n
uh this is always equal to uh
two endpoints
and it's exactly these things here
okay so that's it thanks
so in the in the three by three matrix
case there's this extra vector space of
linear uh
singular matrices
yeah so this is interesting right
because if i look at um just planes of
singular matrices uh somehow it's not
appearing anymore right so of course
anytime i have one of uh something which
is uh
one of these linear spaces coming from
this skew symmetric matrix
i can look at a two-dimensional subspace
of that and the question is well what
component do i land on and the answer is
well i had three choices of components
right i had the zero compression spaces
the one compression spaces and the two
compression spaces so i have to end up
in the middle then it's
the only choice um
so that's where that component fits into
the picture
um i'm not sure exactly what else you
were asking but
so can your methods for the determinant
be used to find new examples of
unexpendable linear spaces
um i think
so far no and i don't see
i don't see an easy way of
of of doing this using using any of the
machinery that we have um this would be
nice but i i'm afraid not
so does this pr of parma n
grows
exponentially in l
do you know this it should grow right
nobody knows nobody knows
there's a lower bound
but it should be expected that it's it's
exponential
isn't this homogeneous
because uh it should be interesting to
know if probably is the simplest case
only compression space component that
could be maybe a guess
yeah so this question has been on my
radar but i but i have not thought about
it yeah
why is it called
uh it's named after the
italian mathematician
i don't does anyone have a better
explanation than this
varieties and so i mean so there's there
is a connection
many mini final schemes are in fact
final varieties
so final excuse
funnel
no no i mean so these are
these are not i mean not even varieties
often right they're
and not irreducible but let's take the
reduced varieties
okay yeah yeah so you can generally ask
yeah i know so this is a good question
and um we don't know the answer but uh
so
so we know um
so when say uh
n is three and k is 5
we know all the components which occur
and these are all fauna both in the
determinant and in the permanent case
in general these compression space
components that you get well
as long as they're non-singular what
they are their their their grassman
bundles over grasmanians but um for low
values of k then they become singular so
i don't know if they're found or then as
well or not
there's this open question of the
definite complexity of the three by
three permanent you know yes yes
yes so this this this
hopefully but i haven't
i haven't been able to do anything so
far but i'm still thinking about this
from what you said it should be possible
in principle to guess the existence of
any controller from the local structure
of the fixed point of the taurus
theory to guess what existence if you
want to do that because
so if you want to detect the existence
of additional components this is right
yeah so you exactly so yeah so maybe
um so well it gets very it gets very
complicated and the problem is somehow i
mean these are the worst points of the
final scheme right in general you have
this non-reduced structure and so you
start um
you start computing things on
macaulay ii or whatever and it just
blows up so
um
for n equals three and n equals four you
can
usually compute stuff but these are the
cases where we already know everything
anyways um
for n equals five maybe if you're a
little more clever something might still
be possible
but
i haven't had any success so far to find
something new
another question
well thanks again